hey leute jetzt wieder einmal waren
willkommen in meinem nagelstudio hey wir
uns lange nicht gesehen sorry ihr wisst
dass ich immer mal wieder in einem
nagelstudio supermarkt laden online shop
bestellen und da wir durch diese locker
und leicht natürlich keine neuen studios
besuchen dürfen
das heißt natürlich ich verstehe nicht
ganz weil die sind so gut mit ihren lexi
gläsern sie eigentlich finde wenn
friseure auf haben sollten aber das ist
ein ganz anderes thema sondern das thema
jetzt hier keine verschwörungstheorien
verbreiten davon gibt es mittlerweile
genug auf jeden fall habe ich auf der
website ohne intention einer wetziker
leser entdeckt das fand ich aber ehrlich
gesagt sehr strange weil ich habe ja
immer wieder bei google adventskalender
eingegeben und dachte das ja ja alle
adventskalender gibt dabei rauskommen es
ist naiv dass sich das dachte ich habe
halt gar nicht anlageprodukte gedacht
aber umso besser ich freue mich mega
drauf also ich meine fingernägel in den
letzten videos aufgefallen sind die seen
wirklich mittlerweile schrecklich
aussieht gehört leider nicht zu diesen
leuten die kurz vor lockdown sich
nochmal die nägel haben machen lassen
aber umso besser dann können wir diesen
kalender richtig gut ausprobieren zudem
die sein habe ich nicht viel zu sagen
das ist aus pappe es ist schön und ich
bin sehr gespannt was drin sein wird so
was hat denn gekostet nein ich habe
weniger bezahlt weniger ich wette ich
habe weniger gezahlt 172 euro steht da
gerade ich habe nicht von derzeit sind
habe ich 172 euro bezahlten habe ich
mich wenig habe ich habe ich nicht hab
ich habe ihm am dritten november für 69
euro gekauft jetzt gibt es den gleichen
online shop für 172 euro wartet nur ab
werther zuhörer 100 sein
das ist so schwer einzuschätzen was 172
euro sind und er ist derzeit nicht
verfügbar
wahrscheinlich haben sie einfach nicht
so viele produziert oder er ist so
beliebt in der nagel community und ich
wusste es nicht denn gerade wieder
schockiert dass es hier wieder 172 euro
sind weil ich dachte noch 69 euro ok
guter preis für wahrscheinlich gute
produkte und märkte 70 euro gestartet
dann ein
mit türchen nummer eins so der kann
sogar stehen ist das nicht toll ist aber
auch so geil sagt jens kalender kann
nicht stehen wo geil dass dieses ganze
zeug das ich niemals bestellen würde
weil das halt so stickstoff eine
handcreme mit zimtschnecken duft ich
weiß nicht ob man möchte dass die hand
nachts sind schnecke riecht aber
grundsätzlich habe ich auch noch nicht
zugegen
[Musik]
falls ich hier die ganze zeit aus raffte
müssen wir es natürlich wieder sagen
dieses videos nicht gesponsert und jetzt
alle zusammen
dieses videos nicht gesponsert wow
es riecht perfekt aber handcreme das
heißt wenn man sich halt die fingernägel
gemacht hat und alles pipapo fertig ist
wo man kann es ja auch so benutzten sie
trägt aus ihnen studio produkt also die
creme ist absolut gut sie riecht sehr
schön nachts im schnecke
falls sie ein bisschen bock auf außen
gehabt dacia nummer zwei so wir starten
wir den nagel produkten elegance
delitzscher viele diesen adventskalender
sehr gerne mit einer nageldesignerin
ausgepackt ich glaube der cool gewesen
noch mal so eine expertenmeinung das ist
wirklich ali genc drittel verein ist das
griplevel alter nur gewerbliche
anwendungen spaß ja man muss halt
vorsichtig sein wenn man sich zu hause
selber die nie gemacht ist das daran
muss man denken kann dinge falsch machen
und wenn man dinge falsch macht kann es
halt zu nagelpilz kommt zu verletzungen
verbrennungen
vielleicht auch mal kurz die zweite
kamera damit ihr es auch hier gesehen
könnte hier sieht man das einmal im nah
dieses wunderschöne glitzer und wir
machen weiter mit dem nächsten monat 30
groß aber der inhalt ist einfach mega
klein wir haben hier eine sehr kleine
tube mit einem sehr komischen aufsatz
haben wir auch keine anleitung das ist
so ein kleiner minuspunkt es wäre schön
gewesen so ein kleines büchlein zu haben
aber andererseits sollte man ja auch als
profi wissen es ist er ja ich denke wird
es noch mal wird es ist weihnachtlich
mit glitzer denkmal dieser aufsatz ist
dafür da damit das sehr fein aufgetragen
werden kann nummer vier ist riesengroß
ritschel ihn nicht drin wäre es also
nicht absichtlich grad
also was ich schön finde ist ich glaube
die haben sich wirklich gedanken gemacht
was weihnachtliches zu gestalten in
einem level designer duos kalender
sollte auch eine nagelfeile seien aber
gut dann benutzen ja auch wirklich die
produkte die wir in diesem kalender
haben türchen nummer 55 euro das ist
eine große packung krümmt geweiht weiß
nicht ob ich jemals krügel benutzt habe
von riolit ihn aber das glaube ich alles
von schon also ich meine ich habe ja das
internet so ich kann alle fragen ins
internet stellen wow das ist dieses
festival womit man glaube ich auch seine
fingernägel verlängern kann wenn man
diese schablonen hat bestimmt gab es
eine erklärung anleitung oder irgendwas
ich habe sie nur weggeschmissen
ich habe kein groß ich habe ihm hallo
die in klein und das sieht dann immer so
nach proben aus aber das sieht nach
nagelstudio ist okay nikolaus ich habe
das gefühl nikolaus mit hier sehr groß
zelebriert beziehungsweise wünsche ich
mir dass wahrscheinlich einfach nur es
ist schwer mit vanille koch also ich
finde die sieht sehr schön aus kann man
sich dann in einem nagelstudio
entstellen das design erinnert mich an
aber und das ist ja zurzeit so die in
grenzer kerzen marke ich wollte mir eine
von aaron may kaufen
ich muss sagen ist einzige was mich noch
abschreckt ist der preis bei der ist
wirklich stolz
für 69 euro werde ich total zufrieden
sein mit der ausbeute frage mich was ist
wenn es 172 gekostet hätte natürlich
noch mal sieht man bekommt richtig lust
sich jetzt die fingernägel zu machen
schellack schau mal also scheller in
babyblau und ist es ein thermo lag das
heißt es verändert die farbe
ich frag mich hin was ist die farbe
verändert findet eigentlich kugelmann
kalte finger hat dann hat man eine farbe
und wenn sie warm werden zu hause zum
beispiel dann kriegen sie eine andere
farbe das gute ist dass man den halt so
easy aufträgt fest macht und dann ist es
wie nagellack der nur viel besser hält
ich fühle mich gerade wie würden so ein
ernsthafter nageldesign kanal also dass
der tolle vorteil bei scheller disco ins
g8 hier ist die acht stamping gel
mermaid magenta der kalender wird auf
jeden fall auch wiederverwendet ja ich
mache es mal so ganz leicht auf also ein
sehr extremes pink ich frage mich was
unterschied ist warum das besonders gut
zum stempeln sein soll aber auf jeden
fall legt man sich eine schablone auf
die fingernägel und stempelt es dann da
so ein ja das ist so ich muss sagen
schellack in blau und dieses stempel
ding in pink ram agenda sind jetzt nicht
so zwei farben auf die ich mich tierisch
freue so meine lieblingszahl hier wird
mich das produkt absolut umhauen es
riecht auch hier schon immer mehr wie im
nagelstudio dass es wirklich cool hallo
das wird auch so eine sauerei geben ich
weiß es jetzt schon so groß gold flocken
das ist sehr weihnachtlich
ich hab das ding noch nicht mal
aufgemacht türchen nummer zwei was haben
wir denn hier
zum glück hab ich diese neue kamera aha
das ist für das vorherige tür in border
fühlt sich so schön
damit kannst du deine hände vom staub
befreien oder du fest ist einfach
beantworten hat auch eine sehr tolle
qualität also sehr hochwertig sind fast
der hälfte war noch ein scheller top
coat ohne spitz schicht diamond
perfekte weihnachtsbaum winter farben
sehr viel glitzer aber weihnachten ist
ja auch die glitzer soll wenn nicht an
weihnachten
dann sollte man dieses team fühlt sich
mal wieder an als ob gar nichts drin
wäre ich meine hier macht es absolut
sind das sind nicht einfach nur sticker
das sind richtig professionelle 3d die
ihn sogar hoch das sind richtige
newsticker und dann mit diesem acryl
glitzer dann schneeflocken drauf echte
die christmas i chris christmas
fingernägel machen die die welt je
gesehen habe
[Musik]
wer dann hören wir gerade so überfordert
wird diese situation ist es ein reiniger
also wenn man wenn man diese schwitz
schicht weg machen will und pipapo amadé
teenie das sind diese kekse die man so
manchen zum kaffee bekommen finde ich
mega geil das ist so küsters ist doch
alkohol alkohol wasser und verfügen zum
entfetten der g modell getränken sie
eine zelle mit dem so rief ihn und klima
und entfernen sie die witz schicht sehr
gut das werden wir tun tisch nummer 14
ich wüsste jetzt nicht was ich da rein
machen sollte vielleicht alle den ganzen
kram aus labenz kalender
aber da ist eine aufbewahrungstasche für
mein professionelles nagelstudio ich
hatte eine zeit lang so lange überlegen
nagelstudio aufzumachen
irgendwie hat mich diese idee bis heute
auch nicht losgelassen also ich kann
natürlich nicht so gut neben machen wie
jemand der das gelernt hat aber ich
könnte ja leute einstellen und quasi die
organisatorin spiel von kathrin
einrichten und ich habe gehört dass wenn
man ein nagelstudio aufmachen möchte das
gar nicht so viele anforderungen hat wie
zum beispiel ein friseursalon also man
könnte glaube ich überall ein
nagelstudio aufmachen nagelpflege öl in
amaretto also die haben aber auch so
einen leichten drang dazu wenn ich
irgendwie cool wenn man sonst schnell
geht und dann irgendwie alles total
weihnachtliches selbst die produkte
benutzt werden wird mich schon in
stimmung bringen das macht man natürlich
am ende wenn man fertig ist und die
nägel pflegen möchte und das ist dieser
ganze kram den ich mir niemals holen
würde weil ich zu knauserig bin und
jetzt habe ich das alles was für ein
glück nummer 16 wieder ein schöner klang
judt eher eine klassische farbe finde
ich jetzt zum beispiel besser als das
blau das ist wirklich so eine kann man
jeden tag tragen farbe nummer 17
barry blatt entdecken sie jetzt in
unserem neuen farben barry platz falls
ihr lust habt in einem nagelstudio zu
arbeiten bewerbt euch in den kommentaren
ja das ist da würde ich auch sagen es
ist barry blush würde ich sagen für
frauen ab 40 weiß es ist eine aussage
damit lehne ich mich jetzt sehr weit aus
dem fenster denn alle unter 40 werden
sagen wo mein gott ich trage diese farbe
auch vor gerne und alle 40 jährigen
werden sagen hallo was soll das denn
heißen wisst ihr was manchmal muss man
auch einfach was aushalten okay das ist
eine farbe ab 40 wenn ich meine meinung
sage dann darf ich alles sagen die
praktisch speckt darunter ist 18
das liegt gar nichts auch oma müller
pigment also haben wir wieder ganz
klassisches pulver was wenn man es
benutzt überall hinfliegen wird nun
nicht dahin wo man es haben möchte es
ist halt so ein polo graphic unicorn
pink blau reflektierendes pulver nummer
na klar warum nicht lippenpflege also
und uns da steht le pen pflege kann
immer darüber reden die geil diese
komplette hat verpackung ist der
mechanismus du drückst hier einfach
unten
[Musik]
da steht lippenpflege drauf es ist aber
ein nagel kalender sehr giftigen sachen
drin fühlt sich gut an ok aber also es
ist ein cooles produkt vielleicht drobny
viele neue linie und wollen damit so ein
bisschen werbung machen wenn natürliche
linie ein und meint aber es ist so ein
bisschen random also eigentlich hat das
nichts mehr zu suchen
die kerze an nikolaus und fand ich noch
irgendein der süße geste aber fürchten
nummer 20
fiberglas manchmal fiberglas geld mit
baby boomer mickey finde ich gut ja
ziemlich schönborn fiberglas g stinkt
ich muss auch noch mal richtig googeln
was fiberglas gel ist und wie man es
ganz genau verwendet man kurz zu dem
produkt also man macht auf die
fingernägel drauf und dann hat man halt
nicht die fingernägel anstatt klare oder
weiße nagelstudio wissen mit vanessa es
ist natürlich schwer irgendwie die
türchen perfekt für die produkte
anzupassen aber wenn ich jetzt gerade so
die produkte sehe das ist schon sehr
große türe türchen ist aber nicht
schlimm wenn man den adventskalender
super wiederverwenden kann
oh mein gott ist das hat nichts mit
weihnachten zu tun aber com worden es
ist eine muschel und gleichzeitig ein
pinsel
das macht die beste mehr wollten gut
aber wir hatten schon pinsel also na ja
was weiß ich wie viele pinsel man dafür
haben kann tierchen a22 sieht aus wie
holunder ist das ist wieder ein produkt
der marke macht es auf und es ist
überall nur nicht da wo es sein soll
schwarzes das ist wunderschön schwarzes
pigmentiert das pulver zum dekorieren
deiner darum fingernägel nur bitte nicht
liegen wenn das in deiner nähe steht
vorletzte für ein pinsel mit glitzer
drin hatte früher auch als kind diese
zauberstäbe die dann so dem glücklosen
runter und hoch und gegangen sind das
war das absolute highlight hinzu kann
man nicht genug haben finde ich und
jetzt kommen wir zu weihnachten was gibt
es an weihnachten natürlich immer 24
befindet sich versiegelung sgeh ohne
spitz schicht make-up schein was kann da
wohl nur für eine farbe drin sein
also das versicherungs geht kommt schon
mit einem pinsel kommt mit glitzer in so
einer ganz natürlichen farbe ganz zartes
rosa mit glitzer 379 euro sollte niemals
179 euro wert also 69 vielleicht ja ein
bisschen verwirrt 179 euro dafür scheint
mir extrem viel wir müssen mal so ein
bisschen gucken
zum beispiel hier dieses große töpfchen
acryl gateway immer sind aber auch
produkte wie es ausschließlich teilweise
nur hier in dem adventskalender gibt
findet man nicht alle also disco sind 15
euro
da haben wir dann hier noch so konnte
die handgriffen 450 bleibt bei meiner
aussage dass es nicht 179 euro mehr
denke ich wir machen mal machen wir
machen mal ganz ganz banal grad 170 euro
geteilt durch 24 das wären sieben euro
pro tüchern niemals
moment okay moment moment wenn wir
müssen man dieses ganze allerdings also
172 euro soll der gesamtwert aller
produkte seien aber er hat nur 69 euro
gekostet also er wird niemals für 172
euro verkauft 102 das ist so schwer
einzuschätzen was 172 euro sind kannst
ist das einfach 172 euro sind beim thema
preis leistung sind wir hier also gut
dabei also ja nee ich bin ich bin
zufrieden ich finde die beiden sachen
richtig gut ich bin das richtig gut so
thema was ich richtig gut findet das
finde ich gut ich glaube das macht mir
hier ein bisschen schlechter unser
blauer dings die kerze bin ich sogar
toll
das finde ich gut das finde ich gut das
ist toll adventskalender ich halt jetzt
mein schnauze an ihr dieses magenta
dieses magenta pinke ding auch nicht
aber den rest finde ich toll nur hallo
über netze haus im schnitt hier
ich war so gut sagen dass ziemlich
wirklich jetzt war das aus dem schnitt
hier ich wollte noch mal ganz kurz sagen
dass ich danach einen schleifer benutzt
hat oder einen fräser den ich extra für
dieses video gekauft hab weil mein plan
war es mir mit den produkten meine
fingernägel zu machen als ich jedoch
meine fingernägel abgeschliffen habe
habe ich gemerkt wie kaputt sie darunter
sind beziehungsweise liegt es
wahrscheinlich auch daran dass ich nicht
so geübt mit dem reeser bin und
vielleicht ein paar fehler gemacht habt
das gebe ich an dieser stelle auch gerne
zu aber nichtsdestotrotz ich werde meine
fingernägel machen in block muss also
ich lasse sie jetzt erstmal zwei wochen
ausruhen wieder ein bisschen länger
werden und dann gibt es im blog muss ein
richtiges e-mails video vielleicht
weihnachtlich genau ja stimmt
weihnachtlich super idee toll gemacht
vanessa ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
bzw ein schönes leben und wir sehen uns
dann beim nächsten video wieder biss
dann
[Musik]